pucker up Amy robach and TJ Holmes pack
on the PDA in Miami So Good Morning
America anchors were spotted taking a
stroll on the pier enjoying the view
then they got real close and leaned in
for a romantic kiss
keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
right and a myth appears holiday getaway
in the Sunshine State a source tells ET
that things between them are solid we're
told Amy and TJ are going strong and are
committed to quote exploring their
relationship and seeing where it takes
them
quote they haven't been shy with their
public affection in the past couple
weeks and seem unfazed by their
relationship coming to light before they
were snapped smooching in Miami they
were photographed together at the
Atlanta airport the day after Christmas
hey there everybody good afternoon
welcome
to gym A3 what you need to know on this
Friday you know it's too bad it's Friday
it's been a great week before this one
to keep going and going and going just
enjoy it in November news broke of Amy
and TJ's relationship which they
previously kept on the down low A source
told ET it had been quote going on in
secret for quite some time another
source confirms ET the co-anchor
separated from their spouses over the
summer TJ split from his wife attorney
Marilee fee big after getting married in
2010 and Amy called it quits with her
husband Andrew Shu also after 12 years
of marriage Andrew and I are in our
second marriage we have a blended family
we have step children but it was not
easy and sometimes it still isn't easy
as a result of Amy and TJ's romance ABC
News launched an investigation to see if
they violated any company policies the
investigation is still ongoing and for
the time being they have been suspended
on air
foreign